APPARENTLY THEY ARE HOLDING
MR. BANNON TO ONE STANDARD AND
WE PRESS ON.
ADAM SCHIFF.
THE DECISION HAS BEEN MADE BY
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE OUT THE
MEMO PRODUCED BY THE REPUBLICANS
ON THE COMMITTEE LOOKING AT
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ABOUT
SURVEILLANCE DURING THE CAMPAIGN
SURVEILLANCE DURING THE CAMPAIG
CAMPAIGN.
HERE IS A COMPILATION EARLIER OF
SOME LAWMAKERS, WHETHER THIS
MEMO SHOULD BE RELEASED OR NOT.
>> IT CERTAINLY SHOULD BE BUT
SOMEBODY SHOULD EXPLAIN HOW
UTTERLY INSIGNIFICANT IT IS.
>> THIS MEMO ANSWERS WHAT I
THINK ARE REALLY LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS AND I DO THINK THE FBI
SHOULD LOOK AT IT BEFORE IT IS
RELEASED.
>> I DON'T WANTED RELEASED YET.
I WANT SOMEBODY WHO IS WITHOUT A
POLITICAL BIAS TO COME IN AND
LOOK AT THE ALLEGATIONS.
THE WAY THE FBI CONDUCTED ITSELF
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BOTHERS ME.
>> NO ONE AT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
SEEN THE MEMO.
IT WOULD BE HARD FOR US TO MAKE
A DECISION.
>> Bret: OTHER LAWMAKERS SAY
THEY ARE TREMENDOUSLY DISTURBED
BY WHAT THEY SEE IN THE MEMO AND
WANT TO GET IT OUT.
THAT'S THE POSITION THE
COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN TONIGHT,
VOTING ALONG PARTY LINES TO DO
EARLY.
TOM BEVAN, REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
CHARLES LANE, OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
WE WANT TO LET THAT BREATHE A
THE REPUBLICAN MEMO BUT THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO VOTING NOT TO
RELEASE IT.
>> THIS IS A SUMMARY MEMO.
A FOUR-PAGE MEMO, A SUMMATION OF
A YEAR'S WORTH WORTH OF WORK,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PAGES
OF TESTIMONY AND VISITS TO
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND SPEAKING
WITH ALL SORTS OF PEOPLE.
WHAT BROKE TODAY ABOUT
HAVE A PRETTY GOOD BIG SITUATION
ON OUR HANDS.
HE'S ONLY THE MOST RECENT PERSON
TO BE DEMOTED, STEPPED DOWN, OR
RESIGNED AFTER INQUIRIES INTO
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT FBI.
YOU HAD BRUCE OR, PETER STRZOK,
BAKER, TAKEN -- WHO IS GONE.
AND JAMES RYBICKI.
IT'S QUITE A COLLECTION OF
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA ARE
MISSING THIS LARGE STORY PERHAPS
THIS MEMO WILL HELP US LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT'S CAUSING THESE CHANGES.
>> Bret: DEPUTY DIRECTOR
LEAVES TODAY OR ABRUPTLY.
GENERAL REPORT EXAMINING THE
ACTIONS OF MR. McCABE AND
OTHER SENIOR I FBI OFFICIALS
DURING THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN WHEN THE BUREAU WAS
INVESTIGATING BOTH
HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAIL USE AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN CONNECTION
ONE FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL CLOSE TO MR. McCABE,
WHICH WOULD'VE BEEN A DEMOTION.
CAPITOL HILL.
>> COULD BE A COINCIDENCE BUT
IT'S PROBABLY SAFE TO ASSUME
THERE ARE NO COINCIDENCES WITH
REGARD TO THIS SITUATION.
I THINK MOLLIE IS RIGHT, IT'S A
BIG DEAL, THE FACT THAT NUMBER
TWO AT THE FBI HAS BEEN REMOVED,
STEPPED DOWN, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO SAY.
THE RELEASE OF THE MEMO IT'S
GOING TO COME IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS, IT APPEARS MOST LIKELY WE
ARE GOING TO SEE THIS, IT'S
GOING TO SHED SOME LIGHT, A LOT
OF LIGHT ON WHY HE STEPPED DOWN
ON WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON BEHIND
THE SCENES.
>> Bret: THE PARTISAN LOOK AT
THE SKY THE FACT THAT THIS IS IT
ALONG PARTY LINES, THE FACT THAT
TWO DIFFERENT LAWMAKERS FROM TWO
PARTIES CAN LOOK AT THE SAME
THING AND SEE SOMETHING DIRECTLY
DIFFERENT AND OPPOSITE.
GRAHAM WHO SAID I WANT SOMEONE
WITHOUT A POLITICAL BIAS TO LOOK
AT THIS BEFORE IT'S RELEASED.
MY THOUGHT WAS WHERE IS HE GOING
TO FIND THAT SOMEONE?
DEMOCRAT, HAS SAID IT'S GOING TO
WIND UP LIKE AL CAPONE'S VAULT.
A BIG NOTHING BURGER.
ABUSE OF AUTHORITY THEY'VE EVER
SEEN.
IT IS SUPPOSED TO BEAR ON THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE STEELE
DOSSIER INFLUENCE THE FISA
WARRANT.
>> Bret: CHRISTOPHER STEELE AS
RECEIVED MONEY FROM THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
DNC TO DO OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
>> WHAT I WILL BE LOOKING FOR IN
THE DOCUMENT TO MAKE MY OWN
CAN THEY REALLY SHOW THAT IF NOT
FOR THE STEELE DOSSIER, THIS
FISA WARRANT WOULD NOT OF AN
ISSUE.
THAT WOULD BE A BIG DEAL.
IF IT IS MORE MURKY THAN THAT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO STILL HAVE
ARGUMENTS.
DISCUSSION ABOUT THESE THINGS.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT WHETHER THE
FISA APPLICATION WAS BASED
SOLELY ON THIS DOSSIER BUT IF IT
DOCUMENT PAID AND FUNDED BY THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND WE
KNOW AND ARE McCABE SAID
RECENTLY THERE WAS NOTHING IN
THE DOSSIER VERIFIED OTHER THAN
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
THERE WERE OTHER WAYS THE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
TREASONOUS COLLUSION BETWEEN
TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
IT WAS THE FACT OF THE DOSSIER
BEING BRIEFED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA AND LEECHED
TO A MEDIA OUTLET THAT KIND OF
CREATED THIS POSTER THAT WOULD
BENEFIT SUBJECT TO DO FOR A
YEAR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS AND
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
SENIOR FBI OFFICIALS WERE DOING.
>> Bret: THE FACT THAT WE ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT WHICH ALSO
SHOULD BE COMING OUT SOON,
WHETHER WE GET TO SEE IT OR NOT,
IT'S GOING TO BE THERE.
>> CARRIES MORE WEIGHT THAN
EITHER PARTISAN MEMO.
BUT LET'S RELEASE EVERYTHING.
LET'S HAVE THE PUBLIC HAVE THE
INFORMATION.
THE ARGUMENT TO PUBLISH THE
DOSSIER A YEAR AGO WAS THAT THIS
SOMETHING THAT HAD AN EFFECT
INSIDE THE GOVERNMENT.
LET'S SEE IT AND LEFT THE PUBLIC
MAKE THEIR DETERMINATION.
MEMO HINTS TOWARDS ROSENSTEIN,
AND HE IS THE PERSON WHO COULD
GET RID OF MUELLER.
>> I GUESS THE IDEA IS HE
RENEWED THE FISA WARRANT AFTER
>> IT COULD SHOW THAT A MEMBER
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THOUGHT IT WAS A VALID FISA
TROUBLE WITH THE PRESIDENT OR HE
IS IN TROUBLE WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S CRITICS.
ON THIS POINT OH WHY, THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE IG
REPORT AND McCABE STEPPING
DOWN, THE PRESIDENT, OR JEFF
McCABE A WEEK AGO.
IT COULD BE THAT WRAY HAS SEIZED
ON THE IG REPORT TO GIVE JEFF
SESSIONS WHAT HE WANTED.
REPORT AND THAT THIS SOMEHOW
WANTED TO GO.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER HE ONLY HAD
PAYCHECK.
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
DIFFERENCE THE SNAKES AT THE
FBI, IT'S NOT THAT GREAT.
>> Bret: A LOT OF BREAKING
NEWS.
WE TOOK THE DEMOCRATS WHO CAME
TO THE MICROPHONES THEY ARE
OUTSIDE THE MEETING.